should be a great day on my way to
breakfast with that Comstock the most
senior executives at GE she's a real
innovator always has a pulse on where
things are going
you know actually in a lot of ways
connect with her as as a executive and a
business person I think she has a
tremendous balance of caring about
what's emerging and what's poppin so we
need printing social media it's a
reality online video you know just
whatever really she's been at the
forefront for a big company of being
early and often and tasting it while
also in my opinion always being grounded
in the practicality of business
I think it's that 8020 rule that I'm
proud of that I do which is uh
which is 80% meat-and-potatoes 80% meat
potatoes you know run the agency make
money sell wine you know in the store
online but innovate 20% real 20% real
not half-assing it like really musically
anchor figuring out snapchat long before
the ROI is obvious but making those bets
to where the puck is gonna go and and
having that real cadence not letting it
become 90 10 not letting it become 70/30
one man's point of view on how how to be
very successful in a modern world I
think that does that's how'd you feel
about yesterday's daily be light
fire away Craig fire away people ask me
what happened to Mike my trainer
something happened nothing happened we
just ran our two-year contract out two
years every day of your life on somebody
else's schedule on every whim and need
that they want that's a tough grind so
like them an amazing job and I miss him
dearly
still ran for another month
but Jordan and I are starting our
cadence and our system and where we go
three years for Jordan thanks guys for I
think the sherbert is stunningly
imported and it's gonna become like a
thing like other people gonna copy and
it's gonna become a thing that Facebook
said I've got to respond to right I
think so
there's this quote that people are going
crazy for
no snapchat
yep
if you lack optimism it's game over it's
true like it's just true like if you
can't look for the bright side or or
look at the half glass full or be
optimistic and pessimistic if you can't
do that you just absolutely have no
chance of winning because it's all how
one synthesizes what's in front of them
if you know what I mean like it's like
life's hard enough the game's hard
enough the markets hard enough against
you that if you're against yourself
that's too stacked the deck becomes too
stacked without to go on Facebook live
for an episode of askgaryvee go check it
now
Wow speed in which snapchat is
innovating its product is grossly
underestimated as to one of the
rationales to a type of growth like
people don't get it
like that [ __ ] matters from a branding
perspective guys in a product
perspective hello hey everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and this is episode
208 of the askgaryvee show
this is a very very very special episode
of the askgaryvee show using it and then
commentating on it you will create a
much bigger awareness funnel and then
people like oh I want to use that girl
that guy they're good at snapchat
Instagram and wedding photos hello nice
hair bro give a good job you guys doing
oh yes yes good job you know how's it
going good morning how are you my friend
good
that games alright I gotta go love you
doctor
I was literally laying there for like 10
minutes like you know do you know do you
know what's crazy spin and this is not a
joke
it actually ended up being a great
moment I literally sat there in the
blood I know you know how I get I'm like
I'm gonna die and I was like you know I
was pretty pumped with like the way it
all played out I'm like I like you know
yeah no that was not a fun moment
well
I don't think they're gonna come you
know and there's Playa Mike it looks
sounds like he's gonna come for a night
to play tennis
love you
do it dandy I'll call you right back
nope you detention all right I know all
right bye dude how are ya like half
asleep how's it going good what's going
on
things are good dad thanks really good
two years of working out every day no
adds up so glad we ran into each other
say say hi say hi to Lisa how's it going
I'll see you soon how you doing
yes how you feeling I heard my mom told
me the other day it's a it's a girl
right yeah yeah we're talking about it
oh is that right my brother rocks you
off is that right you well we ran into
each other say hi for me it's 1151 in
the morning it's been an eventful as
[ __ ] Freddie just a lot of [ __ ] going on
Wow
like hey Gary man hello thanks in the
person managed in a a videos range I ran
this
fifty-one and five
hey-ya good feeling great
yes hello how are you
I am we're gonna hear I miss closed door
your Facebook Alive stuff gets people's
panties in a bunch
right
you were mad that they actually got
upset right you get mad about them you
do know that like that phrase would have
a long-gone if you did make a big deal
about it you're the single reason it's
still around and it may never go away
everybody I'm almost perfect for you so
I gotta have something yeah you got a
haircut it looks great Thanks that
doesn't grow Aggies I'm missing your
friendship yeah
Marcus a second are you alright I'm like
[ __ ] right dick a nap yeah it's
devastating
I'd have stuff that's actually like
you're very upset yeah fine I mean it
sucks it's just like it's a like and
logically it was so much better than I
could have expected going in but like
from last thing I bring now exactly
exactly
being a real Thunder fan but dorrance
gonna stay in every night is that true
there's almost no way he's not gonna I
don't always know that's true yeah the
only place doesn't want to be logically
actually that's the one place you get
you said almost every source is like
there's no chance he goes that he would
doesn't want to go back home no one no
player wants to go back home does it
want to be the gentle water back course
but oh thanks for the kind words
absolutely yeah real pleasure rocks yeah
thank you
are you there how are you man it's gonna
see I'm missing you a long time
oh god it's so nice yeah it's nice did
you get the invite for Jude oh yeah I
forgot I actually completely forgot I'm
gonna move these guys thanks for that
note are you gonna be up there or you
got them are you going out this weekend
really no okay but baseball right maybe
do you rock look up in the ICC page sure
but
it's um it's a it's victim syndrome like
just if I could just figure out if I
could just figure out have it you know
it's honestly probably the thing that I
think I'd you know it's so funny I so
value the practical advice that I give
to people and we live you know live by
example I forget about what I say like
this is what I'm doing
that's why daily B is so important
snapchat but no question no question the
thing that I'm now six months into this
like kind of zone I'm realizing is being
the beacon of hope and optimism and
looking at the bright side the thing
that I've done for the 20 people closest
to me that that centre of energy that
like like you can rely on even when it's
crappy is gonna think it's great I'm
scaling through my content right now
like that like that's the emails that
are hitting me in my soul which is like
you've given me permission to dream like
you like the energy that I have inside
figuring out how to scale that to give
people that optimism that half glass
told them that and then the practicality
like the realness of it of like and
nobody's gonna care like you can do it
but you know nobody's gonna care like
that thing is
the thing that I at least get excited
about because the very motivation but
the thing that I can't avoid is bringing
value to so many people
and it's important
it's important if I can ever get
the Warhawk and this is such a ludicrous
statement if I could get the world to
see the world through my eyes it would
be nirvana
and since I know I can't do that I feel
obligated to everybody who's watching
right now I feel obligated if you rock
honestly I feel obligated to the people
that have rewarded me with their number
one asset which is their attention and
time to work as hard as I can to try to
give them that olive branch of seeing
the world through my eyes for just an
hour for just a second through just one
quote through four seconds of video
through a thirty minute episode they can
see the world through my eyes they would
be so grateful happy
Sandeep
truest [ __ ] and truest [ __ ]
all right Oh sir bruh
looking for this alrighty Rock time to
go home and edit me and see if broke up
big boy talk
it's the best man